Yogesh pop it out derriere stupa - no -
ah hopefully is there hungary okay I
wasn't old enough back to 20 years ago
but yeah
[Applause]
planet Corbyn style second quarter you
were running they had a lot of energy in
the first when you're walking up playing
half court offense yo kids yeah there is
[Applause]
[Music]
dump a number mark yourself ten guys in
the right place gets a hand in there
good pass over this effect and yoke it's
there for the offensive rebound hole
once secured in two he's had a couple
take it out of this get the ball to
Yogesh here we go back to Harris anyways
it in abysmal tonight stop tough shot
there yeah
nicole has got it nicole around
everybody
got it back this have tried to pass it
out of traffic and just threw it away
milord for three no good Martin what
former teammates McCallum Tucker shot of
the night he missing careful now
five to shoot back yo gets piling up
that triple-double beefing it up if you
like
[Applause]
yokas is taking command